[Music]
the only thing that is constant is
change everything around us is always
changing we see things moving the
weather keeps changing prices of things
are always changing the temperature of
the earth keeps rising our population
keeps increasing learnt many more such
changes wouldn't it be amazing if we
predict how things are going to change
well in many cases calculus is the
branch of mathematics that can do this
for example calculus is used for
analyzing the motion of objects and then
to build models to predict the
trajectory of things like rockets it can
be used to analyze the money coming in
and out of a business and then to build
models to maximize its profit calculus
can be referred to as the mathematics of
change so to develop the skill of
predicting change in the upcoming set of
videos we are going to understand the
basic concepts of calculus limits
differentiation and integration are the
important ideas around which calculus is
built first we'll understand these ideas
in calculus if we mostly study things
which change according to a pattern
these patterns of change are
mathematically represented by the
concept of functions so the concept of
functions is the main object of study in
calculus and therefore we will
understand it well and finally we will
see how to use the ideas of limits
differentiation and integration to
analyze functions so to see a positive
change in your knowledge of mathematics
watch the upcoming videos to understand
the basics of calculus
[Music]